here is donald trump  all but confirming that he's running in  2024. take a listen take back the senate  and we are going to take back america  and in 2024 we are going to take back  that beautiful beautiful white house  yeah  i wonder who will do that i wonder i  wonder  yeah so listen clearly at this point  trump's plan is to run unless he unless  he gets sick and can't run you know i  mean he's going to be close to 80 years  old at the time  no no one's health is guaranteed  uh statistically speaking when you're  almost 80 your health is less guaranteed  than when you're almost 70 and almost  16. okay i mean we're talking about math  here but it seems pretty clear that he's  going to run if he can  and by pretending you're sort of not yet  fully announcing it he wants to avoid  having to file financial disclosure  reports that's really the only reason i  can think of not to announce it yet